terrific one interesting aspect of being
at Columbia University is as you travel
around the city people perceive Columbia
as whatever the latest headline tells
them is going on at Columbia so that
when we're the center of controversy and
we have been and frankly we always will
be people would come up to me and say
things are really rough at Columbia
aren't they and I'd say no what's really
interesting is that the extraordinary
work narva has done and I think he
frankly understates how successfully
he's been has led to the phenomenon as I
move through the city of people coming
up saying God Columbia is really on a
roll they don't talk about applications
they don't talk about student
satisfaction they talk about endowment
returns because there's been a lot of
press recently about how outstanding a
job nor of a nerves team have done I
thought it would be worthwhile just
showing you how well nerve has done
nerve this is a picture of your children
that's how well nerve has done
okay thank you she's gonna do it for us
there we go
do you want us to do it now okay
terrific so none of us ever thought we
would aspire to losing only sixteen
percent of the endowment let me just
start right there and none of us thought
we would brag about the fact that we are
among the few institutions pursuing the
kind of complex investment strategy we
pursue that didn't have to borrow money
last year simply to meet cash needs but
I thought it was worth bragging for a
moment about being down sixteen percent
and bragging a moment about the fact
that nerve and Anne Sullivan our chief
financial officer do such a good job of
coordinating with each other on issues
of cash flow and cash needs and as a
result Columbia University was not one
of those who borrowed simply so they can
meet the bills nor why don't you walk us
through these charts for a moment or
thank you Robert this is actually I
think a version of a slide that we share
with our board at at the end of a few
weeks ago and as much as we obviously
know that they be careful about peer
returns people are interested in them so
we share them on the left you see the
one year performance against the
universe to which we against which we
compared herself which is the billion
dollar plus endowment and foundation
world when we were 90th percentile and
you see below that whereas being pointed
sort of what was a median return of
minus 20.3 the top quartile was minus
18.2 and below you see us against what i
would call the long-term leaders in the
endowment world those that at the time
when i got here were the leaders and I
think remain among the the very best
players in this world with all
tremendous investors MIT Princeton Duke
Yale Stanford and Harvard how they did
last year but again more important is on
the right the five year performance
since that is really the period over
which myself and my senior colleagues
have been at Columbia together and we
really think of this is our record again
against that billion-dollar-plus
universe just in the inside the top
decile and again against the
top universities I should give I think
it was probably one of my associates a
special award because he managed to
leave out Yale which is of course the
best performer at eight point seven
percent was left out there am I so I
give him a special pat in the back for
that one MIT at 8.4 we're eight Duke
Princeton at seven Stanford 6.8 6.24
Harvard I think in all cases I think it
shows you what I was talking about
earlier in all cases all of these folks
have done very well relative to that
negative 16 bases won't return for the
traditional portfolio and of course we
are always aware of getting too focused
on these returns but I won't lie to you
I think we're generally pleased that
over my time here we've been able to
establish ourselves with the best if you
took a full seven year view that
ordinary doesn't change much Yale is
still number one Harvard just edges us
out and we beat MIT and the rest are
behind us ordinal e in the same
direction so I think we're at least
pleased that we've been able to
establish ourselves among the the best
players in this world so we animal
that's the past tomorrow's a future so
we have to climb even higher and harder
and be even better than we were in the
past to stay there